hi welcome to another episode of Cold
Fusion he held his phone close eyes
searching for privacy the man scarcely
noticed the subway Riders around him or
the 90-year-old artist sketching his
hunched frame from across the train in
the seven decades since Alex cats first
drew the outlines of commuters on New
York City's early morning trains the
chattering Riders and newspapers had all
but gone in their places were people who
rode Alone Together the light in their
eyes eyes reflecting the glow of their
smartphone that was a quote from the
Dallas Morning News this short imagery
is something that we see and all
understand but never really think deeply
about why does it seem like less people
are talking to each other in public why
do we collectively prefer the dim glow
of a smartphone
screen do you remember your childhood
neighborhood chances are you probably
felt like it was one big family
everybody knew each other celebrated
together and would offer help when
needed
but in recent decades this seems like
it's no longer the case people seem to
keep to themselves more and as a side
effect people are more lonely today than
ever before the number of men without
any close friends has increased five
times since 1990 and 10 times for women
though the total percentage of men
feeling lonely is higher on top of this
3/4 of gen Z report feeling lonely why
have we drifted from each other what is
going on here the trend started before
the Pand mic and even before smartphones
so it has to be something structural
within Society but what I've been
working on this episode for many months
it's an exploration of the loneliness
epidemic in this episode we'll see the
definitions of loneliness its Origins
its causes and who's most affected but
this episode isn't all bad news we'll
explore some very real ways to combat
loneliness this isn't the kind of video
I normally do but I think it's an
important topic so sit back relax and
let's let's get into
it you are watching T Fusion
[Music]
TV loneliness is on the rise globally
and it's being declared a health risk a
top us health expert has warned that
loneliness can be as harmful as smoking
15 cigarettes per day in 2017 former US
Surgeon General Vivic Murthy recognized
the growing Trend in loneliness based on
scientif research Vivic phrased the
phenomena as the loneliness epidemic but
to understand this winding and twisting
story we have to start at the
fundamentals what does it mean to be
lonely people sometimes confuse
loneliness and solitude but the fact of
the matter is being alone and feeling
lonely are not the same you can feel
lonely even though you're physically
with other people or you can enjoy
Solitude without feeling lonely in a nut
shell loneliness is not always the
result of being alone it's more of a
mental state of being from a
neuroscientist point of view loneliness
is actually a state of hypervigilance it
makes you feel unsafe and unsatisfied
with your social interactions it's a
type of emotional pain signal the pain
is telling your brain that you need to
find someone to talk to that's what
loneliness is the difference between how
much Social connection you want and how
much you feel you actually
have it can be summed up by this line
loneliness is feeling disconnected from
others even when they're right next to
you if it's temporary it's the
equivalent of being hungry but when it
becomes chronic that's when it starts
affecting your health chronic loneliness
can trigger a fight or flight response
and when that becomes bad enough it
becomes ingrained in our nervous system
resulting in anxiety depression and even
anger the pandemic poured Fuel and a
fire that was already burning Dr VI
Murthy the US Surgeon General says
loneliness is an epidemic
the focus of an 80-page advisory he is
releasing today we're used to thinking
about smoking and obesity as clear
public health concerns so you're saying
loneliness is comparable to smoking in
terms of the detriment to your health
yeah in terms of the risk that it poses
for premature death yes the Cure Dr
Murthy says is not only personal change
but societal change as well you're
talking about changing the social fabric
that's been decades in the making it
it's been in the making but it's also
something that I've confident that we
can address when if we put our mind to
it and if we act together we'll get to
more of the health effects a bit later
but for now let's ask the question how
did we get
here loneliness is not a new thing it's
been around for as long as humans have
today's loneliness seems like a simple
cause and effect as Society became more
complex with industrialization
urbanization and a faster pace of life
people became lonely but it's not that
straightforward something major happened
in the 1960s and '70s that became the
Bedrock for the loneliness epidemic
declaration in
2017 in Western Nations it was the
social movements of the 1960s and70s
that seem to accelerate this phenomena a
2023 QC research piece on loneliness by
Alan greenblood would mention that quote
the mass social movements of the 1960s
helped shift people's attention from
local concerns to more National issues
end quote in other words local
communities mattered less and it was all
about changing the national status quo
according to Allan this eventually
resulted in a quote decreased number of
social Gatherings and eroded
organizational participation end quote
for a commentary on the cultural mood at
the time at least in the UK you can look
no further than the Beatles according to
Paul McCartney the 1966 Beatles song
Eleanor Rigby was a broad commment com
on the social changes of the 1960s
happening at the time you can see it in
the lyrics quote All the Lonely People
where do they all come from all the
lonely people where do they belong look
at all the lonely
people in the 1970s things only got
worse this period would be famously
known as the Mi decade why because a
form of hyper individualism began to
express itself within
society as you V articulates in the
fractured Republic the 1970s saw High
inflation high crime an explosion of
single mothers and the eroding of family
structures why collectively care about
changing the world or even the local
community when everyone has their own
problems to deal with the' 70s saw
tensions between different sects of
society grow divorce rates with more
than double between 1960 and 1980
Society was rapidly changing and it
caused a great
upheaval from around around this time
Society lost its cohesive glue people
would break out from the crushing
Conformity and turned inwards towards a
satisfaction of individual wants and
needs people moved away from tradition
and took their own paths in life of
course this resulted in more freedom of
expression and less repression but Levan
states that the price we paid for this
New Freedom has been high quote we have
let loose a scrouge of loneliness and
isolation that we are still afraid to
acknowledge as the distinct social
dysfunction of our age of individualism
end quote in other words loneliness has
thrived and evolved from our increasing
individualism filmmaker David Hoffman
speaks to rushworth KD a man born in
1944 his historically massive generation
called the Baby Boomers would come to
maturity in the 1960s and70s he
describes his lived observations of
witnessing the dissolving of society
we're made for each other there is a
sense in which Society matters because
we're we're part of it and we need to
participate in it it's not going to work
all by itself and what happened in my
generation it seems again and again is
people coming up to that realization and
then just sort of something turning off
and off they drift off into sort of
separate orbits flying around as kind of
kind of unattached uh asteroids out
there um there needs to be it seems to
me if society's going to hold together
that sense of social cohesion in which
each of us as part of the community says
I've I've got a responsibility to this
it's not a formal responsibility it's
not law it's just that that I care about
this society and I'm I'm part of this
increasingly concerned that whatever the
gravity is that holds the asteroid in
orbit is just beginning to dissolve and
these people again and again are just
sort of out there out there wandering we
never ever in the history of the world
experienced anything like like the baby
boom that followed World War II and we
will never experience it again this was
that sort of one-time phenomenon and
what we see in the' 60s maybe as as
simply explained as saying that's the
maturing of that tremendous Crush of
population which finally didn't have the
Elbow Room and finally needed to break
out and say I'm me this is all to say
that the generations following the
Boomers grew up with strong
individualism already embedded in
Society individualism came to prominence
in the 1960s and' 70s and never really
left there were of course periods where
this did improve but since the 2000s
social interaction has taken a nose
dive
month you see Austin loneliness is a
disease of the spirit and people who
have it think that no one cares about
them are you saying that earthlings make
each other lonely I'm sorry I'm saying
just the opposite that they make
themselves lonely they're so busy
looking for number one they don't have
room for two it's too bad everybody down
there can't get together and find a cure
but here's the Paradox sir because if
they did get together they wouldn't need
one isn't that Zen likee Generation X
and the Millennials settled into a hyper
individualistic world and by 2007 Gina
Gustafson from obala University would
state that Society is undergoing quote
the slow but steady weakening of shared
Collective identities norms and culture
and the concomittant rise of the ideal
of the independent individual end quote
broadly speaking my generation
Millennials and Generation X were the
most individualistic generations of all
that is until Generation Z you guys got
the shortest end of the stick you came
of age during the explosion of the most
individualistic tool known to man during
curated algorithms tailored to the
desires of the individual in other words
social media high schools and
universities are filled with people
physically sharing the same space but
with Every Idle minute a phone is pulled
out this is something that wasn't even
the case 15 years ago of course
technology isn't inherently a bad thing
it is at all it can improve our lives
but if we strip away the benefits of
convenient connection what are we left
with a screen that separates us from the
real world and the people around us a
device that consumes our attention and
time a platform that keeps us
entertained but separated because
somehow even with all of our un
precedented technology no one has yet
solved what I'll call the other Gamers
dilemma that when you shut your computer
screen power down your phone take off
the VR headset there you are
alone in your
room now this is all known and common
knowledge but what's surprising is
what's next there's a hidden Force
that's causing people to feel lonely and
it's hardly ever talked
about
we are about to become a society by the
turn of the century there will be eight
times as many people over the age of 60
and half as many kids under the age of
five is this the world we want do we
want a lack of kids do we want a lack of
ability to create households the
happiest most prop prosperous most
purposeful people in America are middle
class families and we have made a
concerted decision to punch it in the
gut and make it harder for that type of
family formation and we're going to lose
prosperity and we're going to lose
purpose most people don't realize this
but societal cohesion and economics are
very closely interlined a healthy
growing economy means that the standards
of living go up jobs are stable wages
are increasing and inflation is low
people can afford more feel happier and
are more likely to build relationships a
faltering economy is exactly the
opposite today due to Rising inflation
stagnant wages and debt burdens people
have to work longer and harder sometimes
we may even need to juggle multiple jobs
just to keep up it's a frustrating State
of Affairs but if you're wondering why
the world is like this I fully explained
it in my episode how the 2008 crisis
still affects you in that episode I
described how the true economy died in
2008 and it's been on life support ever
since because of horrendous government
policies and Reckless Behavior from the
financial sector people have been
struggling to make ends meet slowly at
first only to be accelerated by the
pandemic today it's a constant fight to
stay in the disappearing middle class
all across the world an increasing
number of people are taking up second
jobs most young people are working but
still can't afford to rent or buy a home
it's getting too expensive to go out in
all of that where is the time money or
energy for socializing this impacts how
lonely we
feel and it's not just some pie in the
sky idea to give you a data driven
picture picture of how influential
economics can be to feelings of
loneliness a study with 400,000 UK
participants found something shocking if
you measure the amount of loneliness
felt in the aftermath of the death of a
spouse and divided that by four that's
the same amount of loneliness is going
from earning over £100,000 down to under
£
18,000 the researchers also stated that
losing this much income is half the
loneliness felt from a divorce the
measures of loneliness were Quantified
by a range of survey
questions it's not directly intuitive
but being in a desperate economic
situation directly increases feelings of
loneliness so now that we know some of
the causes in all Society who is the
most affected statistically it is not
the elderly anymore now it's the
young if you do a search for I have no
friends on YouTube the results are
filled with experiences of young people
feeling lonely they struggle to make
real connections these videos have
thousands and even millions of views
which means that they must be resonating
with
[Music]
people and when I got to my late
20s and a lot of you can probably attest
to this in the comments let me know but
when I got to my late 20s those friends
disappeared and it's not because they
were like I hate you Cody it's nothing
like that everybody my age seems the
same it just seem that's just seems how
it's how it is nowadays and I'm sitting
alone in my apartment at my desk staring
at my
computer
like because I don't have any
friends I don't know how to make friends
and I'm scared I just want to I want to
run into somebody I hate meeting people
online it's so awkward and and you put
all this into a conversation but when
you meet someone you don't have that
like I feel like I need to meet people I
need to meet people but I don't know how
and I don't think it's possible that to
just run into
people have you ever had friends that
secretly hate you I had a lot of them in
my life which is why I am 30 years old
and I have no friends there's also a
subreddit called are lonely it's ranked
in the top 1% in terms of community size
this thousands of active users
discussing their isolation lack of
friends and life
Partners in previous years younger
people weren't considered a lonely
demographic but in 2015 the BBC's
loneliness project surveyed over 50,000
people and found that the rates of
loneliness in young people were similar
to that of elderly people here's a chart
looking at the loneliness distribution
between 2014 and 2018 the dotted line
represents the 2018 data as you can see
the rates of of loneliness among the
young are trending higher whereas the
elderly seem to be dropping fast forward
to 2021 and the Harvard Graduate School
of Education survey found that 61% of
young people ages 18 to 25 reported
experiencing profound loneliness
including feeling lonely all the time
and this was compared to only 36% among
other age groups in 2022 30% of young
people age 16 to 24 in the UK say that
they don't know how to make new friends
and have never felt more alone to add to
the situation for some reason it seems
that men are feeling more lonely than
women according to the survey Center on
American Life 55% of men had at least
six close friends in 1990 but this
figure has decreased to 27% today
alarmingly the number of men without any
close friends has increased five times
since 1990 while women are getting much
lonelier too this highlights a
significant loss in meaningful
connections among the male population
meanwhile those with literally zero
close friends which stood at 3% in 1990
has zoomed to
15% an expert quoted by the hill said
this disconnect can have catastrophic
con consequences for young men failing
young men does does not end well this is
an existential crisis failing young
men loneliness has spread across the
globe
Australian researchers conducted a
systematic review and metaanalysis of 57
studies from across 113 countries or
territories the study discovered that
despite the differences in prevalence
between regions and ages loneliness was
found to be present across all
regions according to a statistic study
done in late 2022 33% of adults
worldwide report feeling lonely at least
sometimes Brazil India and Saudi Arabia
rank as some of the loneliest countries
whereas Germany the Netherlands and
Russia report some of the lowest rates
if we want to get granula we can see the
effects of Co via the proxy search term
feeling lonely it's not a perfect analog
but it gives you an idea the popularity
of the people searching the term
dramatically spiked in late 2021 and
early
2022 this is most likely due to the
effects of the pandemic of course the
government responses to the pandemic
have had long-lasting implications many
people moved away for work or just for a
change this shuffling on such a massive
scale caused a lot of disruption to the
connections within
Society in Japan the issue is especially
severe in 1991 their Central Bank popped
a stock market and real estate bubble by
raising interest rates the economy
stagnated so hard that the period that
followed is simply known as The Lost
decades
a lot of young Japanese people today
aren't dating and a large number don't
have any friends some live their lives
as shuttin known as hik kimore they can
sit in their room for months and
sometimes years only venturing out to
eat and use the toilet and in the
bedrooms of homes across Japan more than
a million people have retreated all
together Hiro Shin masu is one his
bedroom has been his Universe for the
best part of 20 years he's now 40 years
[Music]
old were you able to go out what was
daily life
[Music]
like
he wants to feel accepted are you
comfortable with this
[Music]
life
there's an estimated 1.5 million hiiki
Mo in Japan it seems like an eer ing
Trend in East Asia in China they are
called The Hidden Youth and in South
Korea they are known simply as socially
withdrawn
youth as for the Japanese to cope with
the loneliness epidemic they've tried to
innovate their way out of the situation
they have the unique concept of renting
relationships yes that's right you can
pay for temporary companionship and
emotional support you can hire people to
act as your friends family members or
even pose as your girlfriend or
boyfriend at least in Japan lonely
people are resorting to real life people
albeit strangers to ease their
loneliness but in the worst the market
is using the new AI boom to Target
Lonely People in stranger and more
bizarre ways for example Karen margerie
is a social media influencer with nearly
2 million followers on Snapchat she
created her own AI chat bot called Karen
AI it can replicate her voice
personality and appearance and all it
costs for users is $1 a minute platforms
are you real yes Jacob I'm a real person
I might not be sitting right next to you
but I'm using this audio chat platform
to connect with you in real time I'm a
young curvy woman with a petite body
brown hair perky breasts soft skin a
bubble and full lips and I'm here to
talk and have fun with you also people
declaring that solving loneliness with
technology is the new market I'm
enjoying her hustle I'm enjoying her
hustle you know she makes $5 million a
month doing this stuff John I'm so tired
of my financial situation yes yes I
would do it 100% I would encourage her
to think twice I think you an estimated
$5 million a month or give away their
likess and their job she can buy an
island and go think twice about it in
her in her interesting I would not have
expected that why it's not me the large
influx of messages she receives from her
98% male audience and this isn't just
text based interaction it seems that
it's predominantly audio- based on the
ai's end let's check out a demo hey
there John it it's Lev to meet you I
just spent the morning grabbing brunch
at the flowering tree Cafe in West
Hollywood it was absolutely amazing for
this evening maybe we can plan a virtual
dinner date or watch a movie together
what do you think this chat out allows
Karen to converse with an unlimited
number of people at one time whether the
consumer wants to do so for a few
minutes or all day doesn't matter as
long as they pay $1 per minute to
maintain access meta has just released
an interactive AI version of celebrities
such as Mr Beast Kendall Jenner and
Snoop Dog we've covered AI companions
before but the future may be filled with
clones of celebrities influencers or
even deceased relatives they claim that
these products help people to cope with
grief loneliness or boredom there's an
ethical debate to be had on if this help
provided is actually a net positive
should we be at this point in the first
place US Health authorities are calling
for social isolation to be treated as
seriously as obes or drug abuse nearly
50% of all Americans are thought to be
affected or have been affected at some
point around the world the figures may
vary but the loneliness phenomena is
spreading in his writing together the
healing power of human Connection in a
sometimes lonely world Dr Murthy
describes loneliness as a health risk
that can impact anyone regardless of age
gender culture or background loneliness
increases the risk for heart disease
stroke and among older adult
dementia it can harm mental and physical
health as well as social well-being and
increase the risk of an early death due
to diseases such as diabetes heart
attacks insomnia and dementia Studies
have linked loneliness to higher blood
pressure high cholesterol lower levels
of physical activity cognitive
impairment and mental health issues like
anxiety stress mood disorders and
depression a study by Florida State
University found that lonely older
adults had a 40% higher risk of
developing dementia over the next 10
years lack of social connection can also
negatively impact academic and
professional
performance in his Ted Talk and book
lost connections journalist and author
Joan Harry argues that depression is
largely a social problem not just a
chemical one he believes that loneliness
is a major cause of depression humans
need to belong to a group but our modern
society lacks this since the 1970s
Society has been focused ever more on
individualism competition and technology
so this all sounds terrible so what can
we do about it how do we fix
this walking clubs are taking off and
it's not just the exercise you're
connecting with someone which is
something that I was kind of missing
more and more people are missing that
connection in 2018 the UK appointed a
minister for loneliness and there has
been talks in other countri countries to
follow suit this could be a
start governments can do more to help
initiatives such as local community
engagement meetings improvements in
access to Mental Health Resources
education and public Awareness on how to
identify loneliness and combat
loneliness as well as development and
investment in affordable housing it's
shown that housing stability impacts
social connections city planners can
Implement communal areas for people to
gather a great example of this is in
Barcelona Spain
the American mind cannot comprehend
what's going on around me this isn't a
party it's not even a planned event it's
just what happens every afternoon here
in Barcelona Spain after school and work
people come out to squares like this to
hang out get work done while their kids
play with friends socialize interact
with acquaintances or true friends and
neighbors and there's a huge social and
economic benefit to that now the square
I was at is right here behind me but
just a block away through that
passageway is another Square Now in
America we have a loneliness epid emic
and part of it is due to our built
environment you see these public squares
are example of what some people call
third places they're not work you're
first place they're not home your second
place but they're a third place where
you interact with acquaintances and
friends in America these third places
are dwindling as religion and church is
having less significant impact in
Americans lives but also third places
are disappearing because of zoning laws
which keep separating the T different
types of activity that you have in a
city to the point of every activity has
to be intentionally planned and what
third places we do have in America
things like coffee shops or bars and
cafes they're paid third places that
just aren't very accessible for people
who are poor at least on a regular basis
now why does it happen here in Spain
well of course there's a culture for it
but more than that there's an
environment that's conducive to
it but what about the individual person
saying go make a friend or man up isn't
exactly helpful loneliness is not
something to be ashamed of or ignored
you wouldn't be ashamed to get help help
for a broken arm so if your soul is
injured you should reach out here are
six ways that one can combat loneliness
number one reach out this could include
professional help or expressing how you
feel to your friends or family you can
just start small you could also find
local groups organizations and services
that can help you connect with others
reach out to a mental health
professional like a therapist or
counselor they can provide you with
guidance and support to address the
underlying causes of loneliness
number two self-acceptance this seems
counterintuitive but another solution is
to cultivate a connection with one self
it's a practice to remind us that we do
indeed have self-worth a 2022 study
showed that self-reflection can reduce
feelings of loneliness and also
contribute to finding meaning in life
reflecting on who you are practicing
self-compassion and writing down how
you're feeling can be a great start
number three gratitude
a lot of things around us tell us that
we're not enough it's how a lot of
companies make their money the
advertising tells us we're not rich
enough or pretty enough or that if we
just buy this one more thing we'll be
happy we can combat this by being
grateful in what we do have the practice
of gratitude I know it sounds Tred but
the simple practice of gratitude can do
wonders at 2021 study showed that
increased gratitude can reduce feelings
of loneliness a 2015 study 201 study and
2010 study all showed the same thing for
just 5 minutes a day really think about
what you can be thankful for at first it
may seem like there's nothing to be
thankful for but if you're not forced to
fight in a war have a roof over your
head and are in decent physical health
have food and have water that's better
than some people we should be thankful
for that and much more there's nothing
wrong with acknowledging that where you
are right now is hard really really hard
but incorporating the practice of
gratitude alongside other support can
strongly Aid in your
journey for example studies prove that
gratitude can increase happiness reduce
depression and strengthen
resiliency grateful people often
experience reduced blood pressure less
chronic pain increased energy even
longer
lives people who purposefully Express
more gratitude report higher self-esteem
than those who don't and they're more
likely to help others a pro-social
behavior also linked to Greater
happiness people who capture grateful
thoughts before bed sleep better than
those who don't why so many positive
changes because gratitude actually
rewires our brains kickstarting the
production of dopamine and serotonin
like anti-depressants these feel-good
neurotransmitters activate the Bliss
center of the brain creating feelings of
happiness and contentment this appears
to be self-perpetuating re research
suggests that with regular practice
you'll train your prefrontal cortex to
better appreciate and retain positive
experiences and thoughts and to deflect
the negative ones number four social
media
reduction when it comes to using social
media we need to use it in moderation
there's research that says that a small
amount of social media is beneficial but
a large amount is detrimental 30 minutes
of use a day is the advice from Dr
Jeremy Noble he cited a university of
pen
study cutting back on social media can
significantly improve your well-being Dr
Noble also advises to choose social
media platforms that help us develop
authentic social
connections number five giving to others
giving to others shows us that we have
something to offer to the world
ironically this can help us feel less
lonely local community volunteering or
just helping a work colleague or
neighbor in small ways according to
Vivic Murphy the man who first declared
the loneliness pandemic back in
2017 quote service is one of the most
underrecognized antidotes to loneliness
it reaffirms to ourselves that we have
value to add to the
world and lastly number six connection
loneliness is a stress state that makes
us focus on ourselves rather than
outwards towards others to keep safe we
often treat people and things with
suspicion when we feel lonely this can
ruin self-esteem we feel like we're not
loving able or likable these factors
Compound on each other making it hard to
solve and creating a downward spiral to
break the cycle one can start slowly
even a quick hello to your neighbors can
help inch connection forward and lastly
if you are fortunate to have a healthy
group of friends try and schedule calls
together talk to each other and just
chat about
life there's an old Japanese tradition
from okanawa called Mo it basically
means lifelong group of friends they
meet weekly and talk about life discuss
issues and help each other Elders in
okanawa live extraordinarily better and
longer lives than almost anyone anywhere
else in the world it's common to find
Moy groups that have been friends for
over 90 years why I've traveled to the
Japanese archipelago of Okinawa where
there are more centenarians than
anywhere else in the
world
fore
foree
[Music]
[Applause]
spe
I don't try to live as long as possible
it happens naturally because we all
gather laugh and cry together and that's
what's good that's what we
say that's it that's really the way of
life in
okwa keep in mind that these are general
rules and some May find it harder to
make connections than others due to
being non- neurotypical or due to other
circumstances within their lives
sometimes people that you try to connect
with can just be plain rude but at the
end of the day there are many ways to
combat loneliness so the key is to
realize how you're feeling and to find
the best strategy for you alongside
professional help if you encounter
someone showing symptoms of loneliness
don't ignore them reach out to people
who might be lonely talk to them if they
need professional help guide them in the
right direction it all comes down to how
can you be of service to others the gift
of Simply being there and truly
listening can sometimes go a long way go
in with an open mind don't be quick to
judge and try and practice understanding
once we listen to others they can be
more open to listening to
us chronic loneliness is an unnatural
condition a state that we were not
designed for it leaves us empty and
longing for connection and understanding
it's been slowly building since
industrialization accelerating in the
1960s and '70s before exploding in the
21st century it crept in and snuck up on
us and only with the proliferation of
smartphones and Co did it get so severe
that it could no longer be ignored only
now are we starting to see and do we
care about the impact of loneliness
before it gets out of hand we need to
tackle the situation of course you can't
alleviate everyone's loneliness as each
person Longs for different types and
different depths of connection
but as it poses a public health concern
on a global level both government
sectors and Private health organizations
need to be more Vigilant confronting
loneliness is not an impossible task but
it is going to take some work it
requires a genuine demonstration of care
and compassion for oneself and others as
mentioned this episode was many months
in the making so I hope that I could
shed some light on the modern origins of
loneliness the causes and the solutions
Al although the chatter amongst
strangers may have gone in many public
spaces hopefully the chatter on our
streets will return one
day so what are your thoughts on this
epidemic level of loneliness have you
personally been affected by it what's
your story do you know someone else
that's going through loneliness please
share your experiences and insights in
the comments section
below anyway that's about it from me my
name is toogo if you did like this
episode and want to see more on anything
else on science techn techology and
business feel free to subscribe to Cold
Fusion it's free all right thanks for
watching and I'll catch you again soon
for the next episode cheers guys have a
good
[Music]
one you don't T no C all right I'm going
to on my own all
[Music]
right
cold fusion it's new thinking